last time I played Euphoria and he
played the Sicilian actually won a nice
game against this guy
the Berlin really
okay
let me play something really boring then
just gonna play him with a really really
simple means
sure more interesting than a rookie one
Berlin rookie one Berlin is pretty
interesting
it's for the real connoisseurs
there it is the best Junior in Europe
really
he did really well and then
in the European Championship it's
clearly very good
so now I'm just like pushing the
pushing the pawn to
to
pushing the pawn to A5 and pretending
it's real achievement
it probably isn't
asios is back yes boys
there we go
Allah already playing a GM yeah this is
something completely different
I'm thinking after rookie eight I might
just
Chuck my queen
why not
seems to me to be good content
if he moves the queen I attack on B7
then I push a section
try to get A7
let's say he goes Queen D6 I got rookie
eight take the Queen the Knight B7 and
if Bishop G5 I had Knight C5 back Bishop
C1 and then that shot D3
holding on to the Pawns
now I think at least from a practical
perspective he's risking more than
than I am
best content yeah but the thing is like
these comments like when people say that
they do things for Content like it's
usually best
disingenuous like I never would have
sacked the queen if I didn't think it
was a good move
or I am or let's say that I wouldn't
have sacked the queen if I thought it
would
um like drastically
um you know reduce my um my chances in
this game
so now I just want to do this maybe B
for next then maybe B5
and it's all about this Pawn in A7
uh
should be four is interesting okay let's
just go
good night D6 is a bit of a threat
huh it's not so easy
okay let's go Knight D6
currently run
it's gonna go Bishop D2 I think
maybe I have too little here
I started banking on rookie seven next
even though we trade a bunch like
A7 is still internally terminally weak
I could have taken H4 as well
it didn't seem
didn't seem convincing like he activates
the queen and then I never really get to
A7 I think
yeah G5 is a good move
D7 Maybe
A7
can go Bishop C4
I don't think that's a perpetual
foreign
check
yeah this is definitely not a Perpetual
but
how can I make serious progress that's a
question
let me see yeah S3 doesn't work
okay I'll just go
here then
Queen A2
okay then we'll make a waiting move
and Bishop
I can't go over Rook F7 but that doesn't
actually do anything
oh but I can go here
now King G2 and he has no checks
take
Bishop D5 and we win
okay
this is very interesting
let me see
I thought this would be very strong but
maybe it's just a draft
I mean come since the white is a big
Edge but
no it's a swimming
oh here I could already have gone King
H2
but he could have gone Queenie one to
resist better
let's see from the start
yeah Bishop D6 wasn't the best
look at this
yeah exactly exactly this line
that I talked about this bishop C1 and
Bishop D3
I'm always much better
okay so here
comes that is equal but it looks very
unpleasant
or here already Knight D6
and text takes I've taken i7 yeah Bishop
A4 was no good
this
oh F3
yeah I missed F3
okay but it was decent enough
I'm not not unhappy with that game at
all